let's go next to our caller from the
7:08 area code who's calling today from
7:08
eyes at me yes it is hi this is max from
Chicago hey max what's up oh not too
much I actually want to get your
thoughts on something over Christmas
unfortunately the topic of politics did
come up in my family and most of them
are Democrat however I noticed a lot of
them repeating these centrist talking
points you know things like Bernie wants
to go too far or you know Warren and
Bernie's plans would never work we need
somebody more pragmatic I was just
wondering what kind of arguments do you
formulate to counteract some of the CNN
and MSNBC talking points like that well
if it's in a family situation I've said
before I would simply just try to
inquire as to how they came to those
conclusions so when they say Bernie's
gone too far left I would say what's an
example policy and then either they
won't have anything or they'll say well
his health care plan is too far left and
then you say well why do you think that
so many countries have been able to do
what Bernie is proposing and it's
working better than what we have here or
if they say elizabeth warren's wealth
tax would would never work or it would
never pass or whatever then you say oh
do you not think that inequality is a
problem oh you do well how would you
solve it I think that using the
respectful probing questions especially
in family situations is the way to go
you know rather than saying you've been
brainwashed by corporate media that
that's less likely to get people to
really examine their beliefs yeah I knew
not to take that approach I did I did
try to make comparisons between Bernie
and Obama oh eight since all of them
voted for and love Obama and his his
original idea at least those Hope and
Change and things like that and they're
really owned the only real response they
had was well Obama didn't go as far as
Bernie so that's why I was okay now I'm
curious it's it's not a good excuse no
but what I'm curious about is because I
get a lot of emails from people who say
David when I see Joe Biden polling
80% where are these supporters of Joe
Biden because I'm on reddit and
everybody loves Bernie or Warren or yang
or Tulsi or whatever I'm on Twitter and
nobody's talking about Joe Biden where
are these Biden supporters are the I've
been making the case that the the sort
of center-left establishment democratic
voters they're not participating nearly
as much in a lot of these online
platforms and this skews people's
approaches are these folks you're
talking about who voted Obama and are
more centrist are they highly engaged in
like the Internet political stuff or are
they mostly just watching corporate
media and living their lives I mean I
would assume it's probably more of the
latter than the former I know that you
know some of them are a little bit more
engaged online mainly Facebook but I
would imagine they get most of their
news from corporate media see this is
why a lot of people who are just in the
online space say nobody's talking about
Biden there's no way he has 30 percent
support there are huge swathes of the
voting public that just aren't
participating on these forums and then
you go to Christmas like you're talking
about and they're like oh yeah we're all
world you know Bernie's going too far
Warren's going too far this is why I do
believe the polls that Joe Biden is in
the lead I don't think it's an
irreversible lead Bernie's been gaining
on him over the last couple of weeks but
this is what I think it's important for
us to understand and not pretend like Oh
but Biden is just gonna get crushed he
doesn't really have the support I think
he does have it and it's from people
like the ones you're describing yeah
well let's hope for the best thanks for
that David I'm gonna try to give them
some memberships to your show absolutely
max thank you I appreciate it take care
okay let's take a quick break if you're
holding don't hang up because we're
going right back to the phones right
after this